ha habido un cambio de paradigma.
La justicia se inquieta en sus cadenas.
A nuestros jóvenes les resulta inútil separar sus almas de sus cerebros,
su verdad está arraigada, su integridad insustancial.
Déjame llamar tu atención a aquellos que sirven como ejemplos.
Aquellos que diariamente dan todo,
pero sus reservas son aún amplias.
Aquellos que batallan amigo y enemigo,
sin embargo, su esperanza nunca es pisoteada
hacen música, nunca prueban,
y el mundo feo nunca podría cancelar
la plenitud y la dulzura de su composición.
Ni la verdad no adulterada de su misión.
Es hora de cerrar la boca y escuchar.
Cerremos los ojos y recemos
por la humildad y la buena guía
para seguirlos en el camino.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Aclamaciones)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Aclamaciones)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias a todos,
no tienen idea de lo gratificante y energizante que es esto.
Los últimos tres años,
he tenido el privilegio de codiseñar con mis vecinos
un espacio en Nueva Orleans conocido como Under the Bridge.
En 1966, la Interestatal 10 aterrizó en el barrio de Tremé,
desplazando a 326 empresas de propiedad de negros,
más de 300 árboles de roble vivos,
se destruyeron en el distrito comercial negro más exitoso de la región,
interrumpiendo la riqueza intergeneracional
y deshaciendo el tejido
del barrio afroamericano más antiguo de la nación.
Hoy, después de 45 años de defensa de la comunidad,
después de 500 horas de compromiso con la comunidad
y 80 horas de diseño comunitario,
estamos muy emocionados de que en 2018,
después de capturar las voces de miles de residentes
y el apoyo de nuestros socios locales, federales y filantrópicos,
la ciudad celebra 300 años de transformar el mundo,
lograremos transformar 19 bloques bajo la interestatal en espacio comunitario,
en negocios propiedad de negros,
en la forma del Distrito de Innovación Cultural del Corredor Claiborne.
(Aclamaciones)
(Aplausos)
Estaremos uniendo el tiempo, uniremos la memoria,
vamos a unir la disparidad y la injusticia,
y no podemos esperar para verles a todos del otro lado.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)